does it Amaze you that from small
building blocks where um amino acids you
mentioned molecules let's go to the very
beginning of hydrogen and helium at the
start of this universe they were able to
build up such um
complex and beautiful things like our
human brain
so studying thermodynamics
which is exactly the question of
you know that batteries run out and need
recharging
you know equipment
you know cars get old and fail yet life
doesn't and it that's why there's a
sense in which life seems to violate
thermodynamics although of course it
doesn't it seems to resist the marsh
horizontropy somehow right and so
Maxwell who helped give rise to the
science of thermodynamics uh positive a
a problem that was so infuriating it led
to a series of suicides there was a
series of
advisors and advisees
um three in a row that all ended up
committing suicide that happened to work
on this problem
and uh Maxwell's demon
is this simple but Infamous problem
where
right now in this room we're surrounded
by molecules and they run at different
velocities
um imagine a container that has a wall
and it's got gas on both sides and a
little door and if the door is a
molecular sized creature
and it could watch the molecules coming
and when a fast molecule is coming it
opens the door when a slow molecule is
coming it closes the door
after it does that for a while one side
is hot one is cold once something is hot
and it's cold you can make an engine and
so you close that you make an engine and
you make energy
so the demon is violating thermodynamics
because it's it's not it's never
touching the molecule
yet by just opening and closing the door
it can make arbitrary amounts of energy
and power a machine and in
thermodynamics you can't do that so
that's Maxwell's demon
uh
that problem is connected to everything
we just spoke about for the last few
hours and so uh Leo zillard
uh around
um early 1900s was a deep physicist who
then had a lot to do with um also
uh post-war anti-nuclear things but he
reduced Maxwell's demon to a single
molecule so the molecule one there's
only one molecule and the question is
which side of the partition is it on
that led to the idea of one bit of
information so Shannon credited
zillard's analysis of Maxwell's demon
for the invention of the bit
for many years people tried to explain
Maxwell's demon by like the energy in
the demon looking at the molecule
or the energy to open and close the door
and nothing ever made sense
finally Ralph landauer one of the
colleagues I mentioned at IBM
finally solve the problem
he showed that you can explain Maxwell's
demon
by you need the mind of the demon
um when the demon opened and closes the
door as long as it remembers what it did
you can run the whole thing backwards
but when the demon forgets
then you can't run it backwards
and that's where you get dissipation and
that's where you get the violation of
thermodynamics and so the explanation of
Maxwell's demon is that it's it's in the
Demon's brain so then
Ralph's College Kali Charlie at IBM
uh then shocked Ralph by showing you can
compute with arbitrarily low energy
so one of the things that's not well
covered is the the big computers used
for big machine learning the data
centers use tens of megawatts of power
they use as much power as a city
um Charlie showed you can actually
compute with arbitrarily low amounts of
energy
by making computers that can go
backwards as well as forwards
and what limits the speed of the
computer is
how fast you want an answer and how
certain you want the answer to be
but where orders of magnitude away from
that so I have a student Cameron working
with Lincoln Labs on making
superconducting computers that operate
near this land hour limit that her
orders of magnitude more efficient
so stepping back to all of that that
whole tour was driven by your question
about life
and you know right at the heart of it is
Maxwell's demon life exists because it
can locally violate thermodynamics
it can locally violate thermodynamics
because of intelligence
and it's it's molecular intelligence
that you know I would even go out on a
limb to say we can already see we're
beginning to come to the end
of this current AI phase so depending on
how you count this is I'd say the fifth
AI boom bus cycle
and you can already you know it it's
exploding but you can already see where
it's heading you know how it's going to
saturate what happens on the far side
um the big thing that's not yet on
Horizons is is
embodied AI molecular intelligence so to
step back to this AI story
um there was
Automation and that was going to change
everything then there were expert
systems
um uh there was then the you know the
first phase of the neural network
systems there'd been about five of these
um in each case on the slope up it's
going to change everything
um in each case what happens is on the
slope down
um we sort of moved the goal posts and
it becomes sort of irrelevant so a good
example is going up computer chess was
going to change everything once
computers could play chess that
fundamentally changes the world now on
the downside computers play chess
winning at chess is no longer seen as a
unique human thing but
um uh people still play chess
this new phase is going to take a new
chunk of things that we thought
computers couldn't do now computers will
be able to do they have roughly our
brain capacity
um but you know we'll keep thinking as
well as computers
um and as I described wow we've been
going through these five boom busts if
you just look at the numbers of Ops per
second bits storage bits of i o That's
the more interesting one that's been
steady and that's what finally caught up
to people but you know as we've talked
about a couple times there's eight
orders of magnitude to go not in the
intelligence and the transistors are in
the brain but in the embodied
intelligence in the intelligence in our
body so the intelligent constructions of
physical systems that would embody the
intelligence versus contain it within
the computation right and there's a
brain centrism that assumes our
intelligence is centered in our brain
and in Endless ways in this conversation
we've been talking about molecular
intelligence our molecular systems do a
deep kind of artificial intelligence all
the things you think of as artificial
intelligence does in
representing knowledge storing knowledge
searching over knowledge adapting to
knowledge our molecular systems do
but the output isn't just a thought it's
it's us it's the evolution of us
and that's you know the real Horizon to
come is now embodying ai if not not just
a processor and a robot but but you know
Building Systems that really can
grow and evolve